yesterday I told you about the
Republican Congressman elect George
Santos who got caught lying about his
employment history and he got caught
lying about his educational history and
he got caught lying that he had four
employees that were victims of the Pulse
Nightclub shooting now George Santos has
been saying that he is a gay Jewish man
and it turns out that he does not appear
to be Jewish
I guess he's still
really gay we don't know but the Jewish
part seems to have also been part of his
completely made up story lgbtq Nation
reporting gay Jewish Republican
Congressman elect busted in another fake
claim he's probably not Jewish either
lgbtq Nation writes about a New York
Times piece
exploring all of the different lies that
he told about education and the other
things that we talked about and then it
goes on to say now another falsehood has
likely been exposed Santos touted his
Jewish Heritage to woo Orthodox Jewish
voters but Jewish telegraphic agency
reports that more than likely that is
fake too the outlet went back through
Santos's appearances and claims and
concluded that as with so much else in
his personal narrative there's little to
suggest truth Beyond his own past
comments Santos identifies as Jewish
through his mother although his father
was Catholic Santos has said that he is
Catholic that's common in America for
someone to identify as ethnically Jewish
and religiously Christian according to
the outlet both his parents are
Brazilian his biography includes the
info that George's grandparents fled
Jewish persecution in Ukraine settled in
Belgium and again fled persecution
during World War II they ultimately
settled in Brazil where his mother was
born sounds reasonable Santos's mother
Fatima devolder died in New York City
and her obituary doesn't claim Jewish
Heritage Fatima is a famous Roman
Catholic appellation for the Virgin Mary
what this means is
I've never met a Jew named Fatima that's
essentially what is being written here
devolder is a Flemish name validating
his Claim about Belgian Heritage but the
Flemish people are overwhelmingly
Catholic Santos's sister and his lawyer
all refused comment but Matt Brooks CEO
of the Republican Jewish Coalition told
the outlet he questioned the duplicitous
GOP Congressman elect I asked him about
this he identifies as Jewish so this
appears to be a lie as well now I don't
know it's not Stolen Valor but Stolen
Valor is something we talk about people
who claim military service when they
were not in the military or they say
well I had combat in the military when
they did not see combat in the military
this isn't Stolen Valor but it's
something else is applied to the Jewish
people and many of you know that I I'm
Jewish Jewish Heritage and identity and
ethnicity
are really closely tied to the culture
and history of the Jewish people and the
oppression of Jewish people for 2000
years and for a lot of Jews it's an
important part of our identity and so
when you see someone that is claiming
this and it is made up in this case
potentially to woo
uh Orthodox Jewish voters you are
attempting to profit from a story that
has a lot of tragedy and it has a lot of
horrible things that affects and guides
how Jewish people feel today
without actually having that in your
family history without actually having
lived it and the sum total of the lies
that this guy has told in any normal job
would get you fired uh I mean it in in
normal jobs if it was uncovered after
you were hired by HR that you lied about
your employment history and you lied
about it your educational history you
know the Jewish thing is more of an from
an employment standpoint it's less
relevant to claim that you were Jewish
when you are not but the sum totality of
this in any normal job would get you
fired and um this is a guy who I I can't
imagine that I mean he was vote they
voted for him they voted for him maybe
based on some lies if he had said hey
you know what
I actually don't really have any
relevant employment history or
impressive education and I don't share
an identity with the Orthodox Jewish
voters and I
it's possible that he might have lost of
course it is too late at this point in
time but uh starting starting off strong
an incredibly historic level of
dishonesty from a guy that was
celebrated by many including by people
like Glenn Greenwald look it's
Republicans electing a gay congressman
and blah blah blah blah seems like he
made everything up the last thing would
be is he actually gay and I couldn't
care less one way or the other he's a
liar that's what I care about but it
seems for now that is the one part of
his claimed uh person uh uh personal
description that remains true